مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيتنا للمشهد
والاشتباكات الدائره في السودان منذ ثلاثه
ايام بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع نقابه
اطباء السودان اعلنت ارتفاع عدد القتلى
الى سبعه وتسعين بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من
الجرحى بما تشهد منطقه شرق النيل في
الخرطوم تحليقا مكتفا لطيران الجيش
السوداني تبادل اطلاق النار في محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في العاصمه
الخرطوم لم يتوقف فيما تتصاعد وتيره هذه
الاشتباكات دعت الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار في
السودان وعوده العسكريين لثكاناتهم
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو تحليقا مكثفا لطيران
الجيش السوداني في منطقه شرق النيل
بالعاصمه الخرطوم وسط اصوات لتبادل اطلاق
النار وتصاعد الدخان من عده مواقع
[موسيقى]
كما اظهرت صور الاقمار الصناعيه مدى تضرر
المباني الحكوميه في السودان اثرى
الاشتباكات المندلعه من بينها مطار
الخرطوم الدولي والمقر الرئيسي للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه بالاضافه لاحد
المستشفيات ومبنى وزارتي الدفاع والطاقه
وكذلك هيئه السكك الحديديه
[موسيقى]
من مدينه مروان الينا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
دعني ابدا اولا مما نقلته قوات الدعم
السريع يعني صرحت به بانها اسقطت الطائره
مقاتله في مروي وبسطت سيطرتها على مطار
مروي وهو المطار التابع للقاعده العسكريه
التي دارت فيها الاشتباكات منذ الامس هل
من معلومات حول هذا الامر نزار
ليس
من نفي لهذه المعلومه لكن المؤكد بالنسبه
لنا كشهود اعيان وكمراقبين
في هذه المنطقه لم تتحرك او تقلع اي طائره
عسكريه او مدنيه هنا في هذا المطار كل
الطائرات التي كانت في مهبط او في مدرج
القاعده الجويه او مطار مروي الدولي هي في
مكانها منذ اكثر من خمسه ايام لم تتحرك
هذه واحده الامر الثاني صباح هذا اليوم
نذكر لمن لم يتابع الاحداث بانه حدثت
اشتباكات في محيط مطار مروي الدولي
والقاعده العسكريه الملحقه بالمطار كانت
قوات من الدعم السريع قد اتجهت من الجانب
الجنوبي للمطار وتوجهت شمالا
للاقتحام لكن حسب المعلومات بان القوات
المسلحه السودانيه تمكنت عبر الدفاعات
الدبابات والمدفعيه من صوت هذا الهدوء لا
لم يتسنى لنا حتى الان معرفه تفاصيل ما
يدور حاليا واقعيا داخل مطار مروي الدولي
لكن المؤكد بان اصوات الرصافه الان توقفت
لا نلمح اي اعمد الدخان تصدر من داخل
المطار الامور هاديه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الان تتمركز في عدد من المواقع
خاصه في مقر الفرقه 19 هنا او في مقر
قياده الجيش هنا في مدينه مروي
طيب
لدينا فيديو ساعود اليك بعده نزار هذا
الفيديو المتداول طبعا لاقتحام افراد من
قوات الدعم السريع
لمنزل الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان في القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه لا تعليق من الجيش السوداني حتى
هذه اللحظه على هذا الفيديو الذي نشاهده
الان للدعم السريع الذي نشر هذا المقطع من
داخل مقر اقامه
البرهان قربه القياده العامه السودانيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم ولا تاكيد من الجيش نستمع
الى الصوت الطبيعي ثم نعود بعد ذلك
عزيزي المص
فحه
يا جماعه الحديد
الاخوه المس
اكين ناس الب
رهان
مصفح هذه المصفح هذه الدول مخازن يوم واحد
يا سلام
[موسيقى]
من داخل مقر اقامه
البرهان قربه القياده العامه وكما ذكرنا
قبل قليل لا تاكيد من الجيش او نفي لهذه
الصور
وهذا الفيديو لافراد من قوات الدعم السريع
وهم يقتحمون ربما يتواجدون الان في هذا
او في هذا القبو الذي يتواجد فيه عدد من
السيارات
امامنا سيارات صغيره وسيارات ايضا كبيره
في الصور التي نشرها الدعم السريع هذه
المركبات ايضا التي
يعني نشاهدها الان في الصوره وفي هذا
الفيديو
كذلك ايضا
الدعم السريع نشر هذه المقاطع لكن لم يتم
تاكيدها من الجيش السوداني او نفيها ايضا
كذلك اذا هذه صور نشرها دعم السريع من
داخل مقر اقامه البرهان قربه القياده
العامه وكما ذكرنا لها تاكيد من الجيش او
نفي حول هذه الصور اعود مره اخرى الى مروي
ومن هناك مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي السؤال كذلك عن وصول التعزيزات
العسكريه النزال سواء الى الجيش وصول ايضا
حتى تعزيزات الى قوات
الدعم السريع والتي يعني يمكن ان تكون
صعبه بسبب اغلاق القاعده العسكريه ومحيط
ربما
مروي هل هناك من اي معلومات او تحديثات
بهذا الشان نزار
نلمح ولم نستطيع ان نؤكد اولا في وجود
ايضا دعم لكن حول القاعده لم تشير او لو
لم تبين بان هنالك ثمه قوات قد وصلت او في
طريقها الى هذه القاعده هذه واحده ايضا
هنالك تدفق لمعلوماتنا
قناه العربيه ايضا تتواصل وتستجلي الحقائق
حول ما يدور بشان هذه المواجهات العسكريه
قبل قليل تواصلنا مع مصادر عسكريه في
ولايه جنوب دارفور في نيال غرب السودان
حول طبيعه الاحداث الامنيه هنالك اشتراكات
الان تدور في مدينه نيالا هذه المدينه
الواقعه في جنوب دارفور هذا الاقليم
الغربي اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
اشتباكات تدور وسط مدينه نيالا القوات
المسلحه تتمركز امام قياده الجيش في مدينه
نياله
تامينا ودعما لهذه المقرات العسكريه تنتشر
ايضا امام البنوك والمصارف التجاريه
رصدنا ايضا عبر افادات وشهود عيان بان
هنالك عمليات النهب وسلب
طالت عدد من مقر المنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه والمحليه والانسانيه العامله
في مجال الغور وفي مجال تقديم الدعم
الانساني تعرضت بعض هذه المقاهر لعمليات
النهب وسلب هنالك ايضا حسب الشهود العيان
الذين اكدوا لنا بان هذه المواجهات تم
استخدام
الدراجات البخاريه او بما تعرف محليا
بالمواتر
لسهوله التنقل داخل الطرقات حاله من الهرج
والمرج الان في جنوب دارفور هذه هي
المعلومات المؤكده مع التاكيد ايضا على ان
قياده الجيش تتمركز فيها القوات منعا لاي
تفلتات او انفجار قد يطال عدد من المقر
من المتهم باقتحام هذه المنظمات المكاتب
ايضا حتى الاقليميه الموجوده في
النياله بدرفور كما ذكرت من خلال ما نقل
اليك من شهود عيا
الاوضاع عموما ام ملتبسه يعني من تحدثنا
اليهم يؤكدون بان قوات الدعم السريعيه
تنتشر في عدد من المواقع
هنالك ايضا بعض من يشارك ليس هنالك
معلومات من يدعم من من يقف مع من من يرى
هذه الوضعيه وبالتالي يساهم في عمليات
السلب والنهب ولكن هي حاله من المرج
والهرج حاله من عدم الاستقرار انفراط لعقد
الامن اوضاع ملتبسه في هذه المدينه لكن
تحاول القوات المسلحه حسب هذه الافادات ان
تحكم سيطرتها على المقر الرئيسه على
المؤسسات الرسميه وسط المدينه لكن هنالك
تخوف من المواطنين بان تمتد هذه العمليات
لتتسع عبر رقعه جغرافيه اكبر وان تمتد
لساعات اضافيه نهار ومساء هذا اليوم طب
نعود الى مروي مره اخرى نزار والسؤال ايضا
كذلك عن
الاشتباكات يعني كانت قد تددت هذه
الاشتباكات قبل حوالي ساعتين في محيط مطار
مروى بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع لا
زالت هذه الاشتباكات جاريه حتى الان
لا هذه الاشتباكات توقفت الان صوت الرصاص
لا يسمع
يبدو انه اعاده موضوع ايضا حسب ما فهمنا
ومن المعلومات
القوات المسلحه السوداني الان تتمركز امام
محيط مروي الدولي بالياتها وبعتادها
وبدباباتها هذا هو الموقف وهذه هي الصوره
الراهنه الان فيماوي الكهرباء
والماء ايضا كذلك الانترنت كانت يعني
تعاني من عدد من الانقطاعات او تاثر هذه
الخدمات في مروي كيف يمكن وصفها الان نزار
الكهرباء الان
منقطعه خدمه الكهرباء متوقفه في عدد من
الاحياء وعدد من المدن هنا في الولايه
الشماليه او في محليه مروي تحديدا حتى
نكون اكثر دقه ايضا خدمات المياه منقطعه
في بعض الاحيان في احياء معينه وموجوده في
احياء خدمه الاتصالات
احدى شركات الاتصالات انقطعت عنها خدمه
الاتصال وايضا خدمه الانترنت هنالك احدى
الشركات تعمل
تزود المواطنين بخدمات الهاتف الجوال
وبخدمه الانترنت المواد الغذائيه الان
متوفره
هنالك سهوله للتحرك خاصه للمواطنين في
الاحياء الداخليه الامور مستقره يستبشر
المواطنون ان تكون اللحظات المقبله هي
لحظات استقرار بعد ان هدا اصوات الرصاص
داخل مدينه مروي ومن امام محيط القاعده
العسكريه طيب بالنسبه للمواطنين يعني
الذين يقتنون هذه المدينه مروي ما هي
اوضاعهم حتى هذه اللحظه هل هناك من استطاع
الخروج من المنزل سواء بالفرار من هذه
المدينه الوصول ايضا الى مدن او محافظات
قريبه
لمروي املا الجميع يعني التزم
البقاء في المنزل ولم يخرج احد ويعني تبدو
الامور هادئه وساحات ايضا خاليه في مروي
حتى الان والشوارع كذلك
يبدو ان الالتزام بالوجود داخل المنزل او
البيوت هو الخيار الامثل والمناسب في هذه
اللحظه هذه المدينه مدينه مروي هي تتكون
من لحم اجتماعيه
بوت قواحده هنالك انصهار بين المواطنين في
اسر ممتده فهذا ايضا يعني بان
العائلات والاسر تساند بعضها البعض يمكن
ان تنتقل الاسره في مكان تتخوف منه الى
اسره وسط المدينه لكن كل المواطنين او
معظم المواطنين والاسر في مدينه مروي ما
زالوا في منازلهم ما زالوا في مساكنهم ما
زالوا في بيوتهم لا خروج الان في ساعات
النهار لكن يتوقعون الافضل ويراقبون
المشهد اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
ساعود اليك في سياق هذه النشره
لمتابعه اي جديد من مروي مراسل العربيه
نزار شكرا جزيلا لك نتابع هذا الفيديو
مشاهدينا من مدينه بورسودان يبدو ان
الامور عادت الى طبيعتها وبان الامور اكثر
هدوءا في بورت سودان من العاصمه الخرطوم
الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن السيطره على
مقرات الدعم السريع في بورتسودان كذلك
ايضا الدعم السريع كان قد قال بالامس انه
تعرض لهجوم من طيران اجنبي في
بورتسودان الان هذه الصوره ننقلها لكم هذا
الفيديو من بورتسودان الحياه ربما عادت
الى طبيعتها والهدوء النسبي ايضا في
الشوارع كما نشاهد امامنا في هذا الفيديو
لكن لا احد يتكلم
حياه عاديه وحركه المرور المسابقه وكذا
الازواج
اليوم الحياه عاديه
ولكن لا احد يتكلم
حياه عديقه وحركه المرور المسابقه كذا
الازواج
اليوم
اذا قوات الدعم السريع اكدت انها حققت
انتصارات وصفتها بالكاسحه عقب المعارك
التي خاضتها على مدار يومين ونتج عنها
السيطره على مقر القوات البريه وبرج وزاره
الدفاع والقصر الجمهوري ومحيطه اضافه
للسيطره على رئاسات الفرق العسكريه
بولايات دارفور والاستيلاء على عتادها
واليتها العسكريه بالاضافه الى اكثر من
200 دبابه واسقاط ثلاثه طائرات مقاتله
تابعه للجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا التعليق الاول من الجيش
السوداني على الفيديو الذي عرضناه قبل
قليل هذا الفيديو لقوات لافراد من قوات
الدعم السريع والتي كانت قد اعلنت بانها
سيطرت على مقر اقامه البرهان في محيط
القصر او عفوا في محيط القياده العمل
القوات المسلحه الجيش السوداني ينفي
للعربيه الان منشره الدعم السريع حول
اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان كما نشاهد في
هذا الفيديو امامنا الذي نشرته قوات الدعم
السريع مصدر في الجيش السوداني يقول بان
هذا الفيديو لاقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر
البرهان تضليل وصفه بالتظليل هذا الفيديو
الذي تابعناه لاقتحام ربما يعني هذا
هذا المنزل او مكان اقامه البرهان كما
وصفته قوات الدعم السريع لكن الجيش
السوداني نفى بعد ذلك هذا الفيديو وصفه
ايضا بانه مضلل
وكذلك ايضا
المصدر نفى صحه
هذا الفيديو وما نشرته قوات الدعم السريع
حول الاقتحام بمقر اقامه البرهان
في المقابل قال الجيش السوداني للعربيه ان
بيان الدعم السريع مليء بالاكاذيب نافيا
ان تكون قوتهم دخلت الى وزاره الدفاع او
سيطره على مقر القوات البريه كما اشار
الجيش السوداني الى العربيه انه لا توجد
اي سيطره لقوات الدعم السريع على معداته
العسكريه
نقابه اطباء السودان المشاهدين اعلنت
ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الى سبعه وتسعين قتيلا
وعدد كبير من الجرحى ووفق البيان فان عدد
القتلى يتجاوز هذه الحصيله منذ اندلاع
الاشتباكات لا سيما وان الكثير منهم لم
ينقلوا الى المستشفيات اما بسبب وضع حرج
او صعوبه في التنقل
الخارجيه الامريكيه خلال لقائه بنظيره
البريطاني جيمس كليفر قال ان قال ان بلاده
تشعر بقلق عميق تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات
في السودان مؤكدا على اهميه الاتفاق مع
الحلفاء على ضروره وقف الاشتباكات الدائره
كما قال بلينكن بان الشعب السوداني يريد
عوده العسكريين للتكنات
ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه وان محادثات
وضع السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه
مدنيه كانت واعده ومن جهه دعوه وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفرلي
المنخرطين في القتال بالسودان الى اعطاء
الاولويه للسلام
دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه والبريطاني
بعد اجتماع على هامش قمه مجموعه السبع في
اليابان الى وقف فوري للعنف في السودان
واضاف بلينكن انه من الضروري العوده الى
المحادثات
[موسيقى]
ثمه قلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في
السودان والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين
وعلى السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا
هنا في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء
في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق
مشترك حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على
ضمان حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفي النزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للذكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذا
الفيديو ايضا
الفيديو امامنا في الشاشه لسيطره الجيش
السوداني على قسم او على مقر رئاسه
المجموعه الخاصه
للدعم السريع في ام درمان امامنا الان اذا
الجيش السوداني ينشر مقطعا
لسيطرته على
مقر رئاسه المجموعه الخاصه للدعم السريع
في ام درمان وكان الجيش السوداني قد اعلن
سيطرته على عدد من المقر في العاصمه
الخرطوم في ام درمان في مروي ايضا كذلك
وايضا في بورت السودان التي تابعنا
الاوضاع منها قبل قليل ايضا نتابع كذلك
فيديو اخر هذا الفيديو المتداول
لاستسلام عدد من قوات او عدد من افراد
قوات
الدعم السريع للجيش السوداني نتابع
يعني دي حاجات مكتوبه ومقدره وانتم تحمد
ايضا هذا مقطع مشاهدينا كما تابعنا قبل
قليل يظهر استسلام عدد من افراد قوات
الدعم السريع للجيش السوداني هذا الفيديو
نتابعه واياكم الان على شاشه العربيه اذا
مقطع متداول يظهر استسلام عدد من عناصر
الدعم السريع للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم
على الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
معامله معززين مكرمين لانكم جزء ثاني
مطلوب منكم يا اخواني ادعام
[موسيقى]
مع القوات المسلحه ومواقف طيبه جدا
قد تكون المعلومه
سواء
كله
رجال قد تكون المعلومه واصلاكم بصوره
خاطئه قد تكونوا تصرفتوا بحماقه اتصرفت
بعنتريه لكن في النهايه الامن ونتمنى
ويمشي يعيشوا حياته سواء كان حياه جنديه
تبع القوات المسلحه ولا يمشي يمارسوا
حياتهم في وسيط اهلهم وينعم السودان كله
بالاستقرار ان شاء الله
ربنا يثبتكم
في خلقه يعني دي حاجات مكتوبه ومقدره
وانتم تحمد الله انكم جيتوا حيين لاخوكم
في الغوات المسلحه مرحب بكم عوجه هتعاملوا
معامله معززين اذا كما تابعنا واياكم على
شاشه العربيه هذا الفيديو
المتداوله الذي يظهر استسلام عدد من عناصر
افراد قوات الدعم السريع للجيش السوداني
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم التي لا
تزال تدور فيها ريحه الاشتباكات والمعارك
ايضا وسماع ذوي طبعا اطلاق الرصاص وعدد من
الانفجارات في عدد من المواقع ابرزها ربما
محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه ايضا الان اسفل الشاشه اشتباكات
عنيفه كما نتابع في الخبر العاجل بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في محيط
مطار الخرطوم وكذلك ايضا القياده العامه
اذا قال عضو مجلس السياده السوداني الهادي
ادريس ان اتصالات مع ممثل الامم المتحده
في السودان والسفير الامريكي افضت الى
موافقه طرفي النزاع على وقف اطلاق النار
لثلاث ساعات لاجل فتح ممرات انسانيه التي
اعلنت عنها الامم المتحده وبين ادريس في
تصريح للعربيه ان هناك مرونه من جانب رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
القوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
ومن القاهره تنضم الينا اسماء الحسين مدير
التحرير صحيفه الاهرام المختصه في الشؤون
الافريقيه سيد اسماء مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه يعني دعينا نتناول في البدايه
دعوه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
هذه الدعوه التي اتت على هامش قمه مجموعه
السبع
مطالبات بوقف فوري للعنف السودان لاي مدى
هذه المطالبات ستلقى صدى في السودان ام ان
الاوان يعني قد فات لمثل هذه الدعوات
اهلا وسهلا استاذ نايف تحيه لك ولكل
الساده المشاهدين الكرام يعني يبدو تصعيد
مستمر وطرفين على ما يبدو مستمران في
معركه تكسير العظام كل طرف يريد سحق الطرف
الاخر
والتزامن مع الدعوات الدوليه للتهدئه
والاعلان عن حراج دولي ممثل في اجتماعات
دوليه وزياره مبعوثين من الاقليم الى
السودان بتزداد حده وتيره المعارك وكل طرف
من الطرفين كانه يريد ان يفرض امر واقع
لكن في واقع الامر كما يبدو من تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وباقي المسؤولين
الدوليين هناك اجماع دولي على وقف هذه
ضروره وقف هذه المعارك وضروره وقف اطلاق
النار
واستئناف الحوار في تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
يعني تؤكد وتاشي بان المجتمع الدولي ما
زال ينظر بعين الاعتبار الى مطالب الشعب
السوداني التي تريد دوله مدنيه وتحول
ديمقراطي وان اي منتصر في هذه المعركه لا
يعني ذلك انه يكتسب مشروعيه او شرعيه لانه
الشرعيه هي
المطالب بتحول مدني وديمقراطي في السودان
والعمليه السياسيه التي كانت جاريه على ما
يبدو يرغب المجتمع الدولي في استئنافها
بعد وقت اطلاق النار بالطبع الدعوات
لتهدئه ولوقف اطلاق النار هي لا تلقى الان
اذان صاغيه ولا تجد طريقها الى المتحكمين
في سير المعارك في السودان وتحتاج الى
مزيد من الضغط الدولي ضغط على ما يبدو
تسعه له الولايات المتحده الان
التعاون والتنسيق مع حلفائها في اقليم
كانت هناك
اتصالات امريكيه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبدوله الامارات
وبريطانيا وهم اعضاء التحالف الرباعي
والطبع عبر الاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم ايضا
الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد وبالتالي هناك
يعني الان هذه المساعي الدوليه لن يعني
تجد طريقها الى ارض الواقع ما لم يكن هناك
ضغوط متواليه وهذا ما ينتظره السودانيون
والعالم من جلسه مجلس الامن ان يكون فيها
اشارات واضحه للغايه للاطراف المتقاتله في
الخرطوم من اجل وقف هذا القتال فورا
والجلوس الى مائده حوار يعني سؤال اليوم
هو عن الاجراءات العمليه سيده اسماء يعني
التي ستسند اي وساطه او محاوله لتخفيف هذه
الازمه وللتهدئه من
اطراف سواء كانت يعني هذه الوساطه من
اطراف اقليميه كمصر او اطراف ايضا حتى
دوليه مثل الولايات المتحده او بريطانيا
او غيرها
نعم يعني اذا بقي الامر فقط
مستندا الى المناشدات والرجاءات والامنيات
من الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه للطرفين
فاعتقد انه لن يؤدي الى تغيير او وتيره
هذه المعركه المتصاعده في الخرطوم
وبالتالي جهود منسقه بين الاطراف الدوليه
المؤثره وبالطبع هناك يعني اجماع في
المجتمع الدولي يعني حتى الدول الغربيه
والولايات المتحده وايضا روسيا والصين
الجميع الان لديه اجماع على ضروره وقف هذا
التصعيد ووقف اطلاق النار لانه المصالح
الدوليه كلها ايضا ستكون مهدده في هذه
المنطقه وليس في القاره الافريقيه
والمنطقه العربيه
للقتال يلقي بظلال قادمه وكثيفه عليه وليس
على السودان وحده وبالتالي
اعتقد انه
ساعات القادمه ستشهد رد الفعل الدولي الذي
يرجو الجميع ان يكون يتضمن لغه صارمه
ولهجه صارمه تجاه المتقاتلين في الخرطوم
وان كانت الولايات المتحده قد هددت في
السابق اثناء سير العمليه السياسيه قبل
اندلاع هذا القتال بانها ستفرض عقوبات على
معرقلي العمليه السياسيه فما بالنا بالذين
يفجرون الان السودان كله ويشعلون الحرائق
فيه اعتقد ان التلويح بهذه العقوبات هو
وارد
والتحرك باتجاه الضغط من الجميع هو ايضا
وارد طيب نحن فقط نشير الى هذا العجل اسفل
الشاشه
المبعوث الاممي الى
السودان
يقول بان الجيش والدعم السريع لم يلتزم
بالهدنه الانسانيه
جزئيا اذا المبعوث الاممي الى السودان
يقول بان الجيش والدعم السريع لم يلتزم
بالهدنه الانسانيه الا جزئيا طبعا هناك
بيان للجيش السوداني يؤكد بان القوات
المسلحه تسيطر على جميع مقرات القياده
العامه اذا الجيش السوداني يقول في بيان
له بانه يسيطر تماما على جميع مقرات
القياده العامه
السيده اسماء اختم معك بالموقف المصري كيف
ينظر اليوم الى ما يحدث في السودان هل لا
زالت مصر على نفس المسافه من كل اطراف هذه
الازمه
نعم مصر هي المتضرر الاكبر من كل ما يجري
في السودان وتستشعر خطوره الموقف وبالطبع
وترى انه انه لابد من وقف فوري لهذا تصعيد
ووقف اطلاق النار وتعمل الان بالتنسيق مع
المجتمع الدولي ومع الاقليم ومع الاشقاء
ايضا في القاره الافريقيه ودول الجوار مثل
جنوب السودان والاتحاد الافريقي واتصالات
بالامم المتحده وغيرها هناك مساعد دوليه
حديثه من اجل وضع حد لهذا الموقف الذي
يذهب في اتجاه مزيد من التصعيد ومزيد من
الاغراق للسودان في اتون حرب اهليه قد
تتسع نطاقها اذا ما استمر القتال على هذه
الوتيره واعتقد انه هناك حاجه بالفعل
لتنسيق هذه الجهود المصريه مع الجهود
الجاريه من قبل المجتمع الدولي ومن قبل
ايضا الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد لكي يكون
هذا الموقف المنسق دوليا واقليميا وايضا
على الصعيد العربي جهود الجامعه العربيه
وقد مصر دعت هي والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
لعقد الاجتماع الاخير الذي يبدو انه سيكون
له ما بعده جميع العربيه لن تكتفي بالبيان
الذي اصدرته وانما هي تسعى الان ايضا
تعاون مع المجتمع الدولي والامم المتحده
في هذا
التحرك من القاهره اسماء الحسين مدير
التحرير صحيفه الاهرام والمختصه في الشؤون
الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك
وما تجدد ومع تجدد الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في محيط مبنى القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في العاصمه الخرطوم في
ساعات الصباح الاولى سمع دوي الانفجارات
في معظم ارجاء الخرطوم
واظهرت مقاطع مصوره للاشتباكات ثقيله بين
قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع داخل احياء
سكنيه في الخرطوم
نذكر فقط مشاهدينا بهذا البيان للجيش
السوداني ابرز ما جاء فيه الجيش السوداني
وصف اعلانات الدعم السريع بالاكاذيب
لتظليل الراي العام اتهم الدعم السريع
بممارسه اعمال صلب ونهب لممتلكات
المواطنين وقال بان قوته الجويه تنفذ
ضربات لتصفيه عناصر الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وبان لا صحه لسيطره الدعم السريع
على بيت الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او
القياده وبانه يسيطر تماما على جميع مقرات
القياده العامه الوضع في الخرطوم وصفه
بانه يشهد اشتباكات محدوده حول القياده
العامه ووسط العاصمه من الخرطوم يلتحق بنا
طاهر المعتصم الكاتب الصحيحه في مرحبا بك
معي قبل الحديث عن الفيديو قبل قليل اريد
ان يعني تقرا لنا ابرز ما جاء في هذا
البيان للجيش
السوداني وربما انني قرات رؤوس اقلام من
هذا البيان سيد طاهر تفضل
صباح الخير
ياتي رده المزاعم الدعم السريع التي
اوردها في بيان صلاح اليوم على
عدد من المواقع هكذا الجيش السوداني على
محيط القياده العامه يشهد بعض الاشتباكات
ولكن
سيطره الجيش
وهو مقر السكن رئيس مجلس السياده وغير
الجيش
وايضا القصف الجمهوري
ومطار الخرطوم ايضا
للدعاء قام بها
الدعم السريع في بيان الصابر الصباحي
لكن يعني هناك تضارب بيانات تضارب انباب
فيما يخص
السيطره مثلا على مقر قيادات القيادات
العامه للجيش فيما يخص مثلا السيطره على
القصر الجمهوري فيما يخص ايضا حتى السيطره
على مقر اقامه البرهان في محيط القياده
العملي القوات المسلحه ما الذي يمكن ان
نفهمه هنا
الوضع
لا يمكن لاحد
متاكد من هذه البيانات المصادر الصحفيه
تعاني فيه ان بعض الصحفيين محيط الا لليوم
الثالث على
قناه
مهمه هذه السيارات
حتى ان هدنه التي اعلنت امس بثلاثه ساعات
بمبادره وطنيه ووضح عليها الطرفين لم
تتعدى الا حوالي 40 دقيقه المدنه مدتها
كانت ثلاثه ساعات ولكن بعض الاربعين دقيقه
الاولى
اندلعت الاشتباكات ولم الطرفان بالتالي من
الصعوبه بما كان التاكد من هذه البيانات
قبل قليل تبعت هذا الفيديو المنتشر حول
الاشتباكات
في الاحياء السكنيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وايضا ربما حتى ولايات ومدن السودانيه
اخرى ما الذي يعني تحول هذه المعارك بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الى حرب مدن الى
حرب شوارع ايضا كذلك بماذا ينذر
سيد طاهر
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
السريع تلجا الى استخدام الانتشار في
المناطق السكنيه
استخدام الدروع البشريه
لتقديم حده مرات التي توجه اليها
اليوم الثالث المعارك في بعض النوعيه
بظهور
الطيران مره اخرى
لازاله
سريع الى استخدام البشريه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي طاهر
المعتصم شكرا جزيلا لك
لقد استجبت بتنفيذ اوامر القوات المسلحه
منتدبا بقوات الدعم السريع في واجب وطني
والان
استجيب
بتنفيذ اوامر القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الذي اصدره ليله امس
بانهاء انتداب
ضباط القوات المسلحه
بالدعم السريع
ومنذ الامس
فغطت الاتصال
والتواصل بجميع وسائل الاعلام لاسباب خارج
ارادتي
واؤكد بانني
لم ولن اصرح لاي جهه
اعلاميه بما يجري الان من احداث
باعتبار ضابطا بالقوات المسلحه
وليست متحدثا باسم اي جهه
مروي العسكري كان محل تضارب هو الاخر بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فقد اعلن
الجيش سودا يسيطر على مطار مروي العسكري
والعقيده قطاع كردفان وكان مراسل العربيه
قد افاد في وقت سابقا الجيش السوداني
انتشر في محيط قاعده مروي شمال السودان
بعد انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع حيث نشر
عناصر من الجيش السوداني مقطع فيديو يوثق
دخولهم للقاعده مروي العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ولله الحمد
انيه في المقابل وقبل ذلك اعلنت قوات
الدعم السريع احكام السيطرتها هي الاخرى
اعلى مطار مروي نحن الان الشعب السوداني
بعض العملاء وبعض اعضاء الوطن الدايرين
ينفردوا بالسلطه وانكم
ومعنا من الخرطوم الدكتور ادريس لقمان
القيادي في حركه العدل والمساواه الدكتور
ادريس مرحبا بك معي على شاشه العربيه اريد
ان افهم منك موقف العدل والمساواه يعني في
هذه
اللحظات الصعبه التي تمر فيها السودان
اعلنتم في وقت سابق
بانكم تقفون الى جانب القوات المسلحه
لجانب البرهان كذلك هل يعني هذا
موقفا يعني
ضده ممارسات قوات الدعم السريع وما يحدث
اليوم في السودان وبانكم لستم على نفس
المسافه من طرفي هذه الازمه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اخي الان
تصير في خط بتاعه مواجهه وعمليات اقتطال
نحن مازلنا في موقفنا باننا في موقف
الوساطه وفي الموقف العقيده لوقت العمل
القتاليه
فقضيه انحياز لهذا ولا ذاك لن تجده هي
الاعتبارات قوه قويه قوه ضاربه قوى لها
اساسها فاذا انحازت في اي جهه يعني ذلك
بانها تم فرض عمليه
فرط الامني في الدوله فنحن حتى الان نناسب
ونطلب من المجموعات بصفه عامه وقت عمل
القتاليه
[موسيقى]
والجلوس
رغم ان هنالك من بعض من الجانبين كل يحاول
يصير
معربه ولكننا نحن حتى هذه اللح ظه لن يهدد
اي جهه ونظل في موقفنا الحيادي
منتجين بقضيه ووطن بمنتج معالجه شامله
وكامله للوضع الموجود الان
فحتى الان
الاتصالات مستمره في خلال اليومين خلال
يومي امس نتيجه لجهودنا احنا بذلناه وايضا
بمشاركته والمنتدى وكذا حاولنا ان ناخذ
فتره على الاقل هي كانت كنقصد انطلاقا
عندما يكون هنالك حتى يعني لانها استجابه
وحاولنا بانه نعمل ذلك الاستجابه منها
واستمرت الفتنه ممكن يكون مهما يكون
في النهايه كان مبدا القبول بالحدود من
الجانبيه هي كانت ايجابيه
اتصالاتنا مستمره مع الجانبين
وطلبنا منهم الا انهم كل يحاول يريد ان
يقلي
القوات المسلحه الان يبدو ان وضعها افضل
على على الساهله الخدمجيه ولكن لا يعني
ذلك بان كل من كان في وضع افضل يرفض
السلام او يرفض وقت اطلاق النار وكذلك
ايضا مجموعه الدعم السريع
رسالتنا واضحه ونكررها وايضا نكرر القوه
السياسيه ولدينا ايضا مع مجموعه
قوى السياسيه الموجوده
بعد ذلك نحاول نصل لرؤيه محدده
بحيات معالج القضيه السياسيه لكن الان
الاولويه
لعمليه وقت اطلاق النار عمليه ايجاد حل
على الاقل الجزئي لان الخرطوم الان
80% او 90% من الاحيان الكهرباء مقطوعه
لمياه مقطوعه فهناكين جدا مجموعات عايزين
تروح للمستشفيات وما لاقي طريقه فهذه
الاعتبار تنذر بالتارثه لا نريد ان يستمر
في ذلك الخط فلذا رجاؤنا ومطالبتنا
للاطراف المقاتله لان تسكت صوت البندقيه
ساعود اليك دكتور ادريس لكن ان نشاهد هذا
الفيديو فيديو متداول لدبابات الجيش
السوداني وهي تتجول في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم صباح اليوم كما
يظهر امامنا في هذا الفيديو المتداول
لدبابات الجيش السوداني وهي تجوب شوارع
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
الله اكبر
الله اكبر والله
عزيز
الله اكبر والعزه في السودان
الله اكبر
والعزه بالسودان
مره اخرى الى الخرطوم الى الدكتور ادريس
لقمه القياده في حركه العدل والمساواه
دكتور ادريس مرحبا بك معي من جديد هذه
الاشتباكات وهذا النزاع الاحتراب بين طرفي
هذه الازمه يعني سبق ربما توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي بين القوى المدنيه السياسيه في
السودان وكذلك ايضا حتى العسكريه بهكذا
وضع جديد ومتازم ومنعرج في جديد خطير في
السودان كما يصفه بعض المراقبين هل يعني
ذلك بان يعني رصاصه الرحمه قد اطلقت على
هذه العمليه السياسيه
الرحمن لم تطلق من يوم امس من يوم الذهاب
مجموعات
الدعم السري الى مروي عنها خبر اعتبارها
نهايه
وفي الحقيقه الانصاري
ة وحاولوا ان يستميلوا معهم
بقياده الدعم السريع وتم دعمه
والدور بانه يكون حاضنا لهذه المجموعه ومن
ذلك الوقت كنا نقول لهم بان هذا
الامام ولكنهم كانوا
يقولون
البحر كانت خاطئه الان لا يوجد شيء يسمى
العطاري العاده السودانيه صعدا عن يتم وضع
الحرب او دارها يجلس مخرج جديد هذه المخرج
قد تكون في عمليه نتعدى حوار سياسي ما بين
الكتب السياسيه في
ابعاد ان تكون مراقبا لبعض الشيء وحتى
الان كل القوى السياسيه ورغم نحن وغيرها
نود ان يكون هناك لا نريد الحكومه عسكريه
من الصور لكننا نريد ان نتعامل في بعضنا
نريد ان يجلس مع
هذه العمليات كثيرين جدا يفهم بانهم كان
على طريق الخطا ويعدون حساباته ويجلس مع
الاخرين للوصول الى
هذا المرضي للدوله سودانيه والمخرج اشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات عن مشاركه معي من الخرطوم
الدكتور ادريس لقمه القيادي في حركه العدل
والمساواه شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا يتواصلوا الاقتتال في العديد من المدن
السودانيه من بينها بوتسودان وسواكن حيث
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو انتشارا عسكريا مكثفا
وسط المدينتين نتابع
[تصفيق]
صوت الرصاص يصدح في مختلف ارجاء السودان
فالمعارك اشتدت خلال اليوم الثاني من
المواجهه العسكريه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع من بين ابرز النقاط
الساخنه لليوم الثاني مقر القياده العامه
للجيش الواقع شمال العاصمه الخرطوم
فالاقتتال لم يتوقف في محيط مركز القياده
وسط تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
وغير بعيد عن مركز القياده تواصلت
اشتباكات في مطار الخرطوم مسببه خسائر
فادحه هذا ما نقرته صور بالاقمار
الاصطناعيه والتي اظهرت حجم الدمار الذي
لحق بالمبنى الرئيسي للمطار والجسور
المؤديه اليه فضلا عن الحريق الذي نشب في
مستودعات الوقود اثار دمار بدجليه بعد
يومين فقط من القتال كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لمبنى القياده العامه للقوات البريه والذي
تضرر بشكل واضح في شمال البلاد وتحديدا في
مدينه ماروي فان الاوضاع شهدت هدوءا حذرا
باعلان سوداني سيطرته على القاعده
العسكريه بعد انسحاب قوات الدعم السريعه
القتال امتدا الى عده اجزاء اخرى من
السودان من بينها بورت سودان وسواكن والتي
شهدت نشوب اشتباكات بين الجانبين وسط
انتشار كثيف للاليات العسكريه وبرغم
موافقه الطرفين على مقترح الامم المتحده
بفتح مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه لمده
ثلاث ساعات فقط فان ذلك لم يحصل بل استمرت
الاشتباكات في اكثر من موقع في العاصمه
وخارجها وسام الذهبي العربيه
لكن من الناحيه الجغرافيه
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين 8 الى 10 ملايين
نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون اليها
يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه الاكبر من
السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم وام درمان
الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا متداخله في
المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل بين الجيش
وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال حدوث ما لا
تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام
قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد للنزوح وهو
الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن الواقعه على
النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان
الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا
للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال اخيرا سينبغي
على سكان ام درمان ان هدد ت الاوضاع
الامنيه امنهم النزوح الى المدن الواقعه
غرب وشمال وجنوب ام درمان
نفى مصدرهم في الجيش السوداني الى العربيه
ما تم نشره من قبل قوات الدعم السريع حول
اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد المصدر
للعربيه ان الاشتباكات جرت حول مقري
البرهان وحمتي وتم ابعادهما وان فيديو
اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر البرهان مضلل
وغير حقيقي
حتى المبعوث الاممي للسودان فولكر بيريتس
جميع الاطراف على احترام التزاماتها
الدوليه بما في ذلك ضمان حمايه جميع
المدنيين وقال الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع لم يلتزم بوقف القتال لاغراض
انسانيه امس الا جزئيا مشيرا الى خيبه امل
شديد جراء التشد تجدد الاشتباكات
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو صورا تظهر معاناه نحو
450 طالبا محتجزين بمدرسه
كومبوني منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في
الخرطوبه الاطفال المحتجزون يطالبون
الحكومه السودانيه بالوصول الى عائلاتهم
وتوفير مواد غذائيه ومياه شرب في مجموعه
من الطلاب الغين في مدرسه
الحاصل تقريبا كلهم 450 طالب الاستاذ
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
يعني احنا بنتصارع في اكل وشراب
والتعليم والعلاج
نعيد التفكير مشاهدينا قبل ختام هذه
الساعه الاخباريه ببيان الجيش السوداني
والذي قال بانه يسيطر تماما على جميع
مقرات القياده العامه ويصف على نات الدعم
السريع بالاكاذيب لتظليل الراي العام كذلك
ايضا قال بان قوته الجويه تنفذ ضربات
لتصفيه عناصر الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
مستمرون معكم في التغطيه وبعد قليل مع
الزميل فاطمه فهد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات